en este vídeo vamos a hablar de cataluña
durante estos meses nos habéis mandado
más de 100 mil mensajes pidiéndonos que
hiciéramos un vídeo sobre cataluña
[Música]
y no es que no quisiéramos mojarnos el
problema es que no sabíamos que podíamos
contaros que nos estuvieran contando ya
a los medios tradicionales hasta ahora
el vídeo de hoy va a ser muy pero que
muy especial tras muchos meses os hemos
traído al mayor experto en
autodeterminación del mundo de quién
estoy hablando ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a hacer una pregunta quien ha
definido las fronteras del país en el
que vivís por ejemplo supongamos que
veis este vídeo desde españa quien ha
decidido que irun forme parte de españa
y no de francia porque los países tienen
la forma que tienen y no otra distinta
[Música]
no se trata de ninguna pregunta estúpida
estar a un lado u otro de la frontera
puede cambiarte radicalmente la vida y
si no que se lo pregunten a los que
viven en la parte norte de la península
coreana en realidad las fronteras son el
problema más complicado que existe en
política y por eso cada vez que una
región se quiere separar del país al que
pertenece surgen tantísimas polémicas os
lo hemos dicho muchas veces en visual
político el caso de cataluña no es único
en el mundo
[Música]
casi todos los países tienen alguna
región que quiere separarse sin embargo
ninguno tiene un mecanismo legal para
responder ante esta problemática en
otras palabras en las democracias
modernas se puede discutir todo
distintos modelos económicos distintas
ideologías y distintos valores morales
pero nadie puede poner en duda las
fronteras del país en el que vive y ya
sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
porque no se permite que los ciudadanos
voten en un referéndum
[Música]
por ejemplo en el caso de cataluña
porque no permitimos que los ciudadanos
catalanes acudan a las urnas para
decidir sobre su futuro en principio
suena bastante justo verdad pero
imaginad este escenario imaginad qué
pasaría si el 60% de los catalanes
elige separarse de españa pero sin
embargo el 60% de los barceloneses
quiere quedarse qué haríamos en este
caso si cataluña se independizarse
entonces la mayoría de los barceloneses
estarían viviendo en un estado nuevo en
el que no se sienten identificados qué
derecho tienen el resto de los catalanes
para imponer sus condiciones a los
barceloneses
[Música]
como veis es algo mucho más complicado
de lo que parece y eso explica que a lo
largo de la historia la independencia
haya generado tantísimas guerras y si no
me creéis solo mirar la historia de los
balcanes es más para que os hagáis una
idea solamente hay un país en el mundo
que tiene reconocido el derecho de
autodeterminación en su constitución y
ahí es donde nos hemos marchado
bienvenidos a liechtenstein
[Música]
liechtenstein es un país minúsculo con
poco más de 36 mil habitantes repartidos
en 11 municipios
[Música]
pues bien cualquiera de esos municipios
tiene el derecho a convocar un
referéndum de autodeterminación y
convertirse en un país independiente y
os preguntaréis pero cómo funciona este
sistema cómo es posible que un país tan
pequeño que apenas tiene 35 mil
habitantes pueda adoptarse en naciones
aún más pequeños para responder a esta
pregunta nos hemos ido a hablar con nada
más y nada menos que su serenísima
alteza el príncipe hans adam segundo
i
el malestar banco exterior de españa en
el vasco en san sebastián en los éxitos
de los rating experience forma de
soldado es musulmán del base civil forma
autónoma e independiente estatuto 5
baldo certamen en hollywood soldados
states don break
[Música]
1992 el derecho a la autodeterminación
entró a formar parte de la constitución
de liechtenstein es decir que cualquiera
de sus municipios podría separarse en
cualquier momento para que os hagáis una
idea este pueblo que veis aquí es la
villa de raquel uno de los 11 municipios
que componen liechtenstein tienen menos
de 2.000 habitantes es decir que
cualquier bloque de viviendas en una
gran ciudad tendría más población
[Música]
sin embargo en cualquier momento los
ciudadanos de roquel podrían convocar un
referéndum y convertirse en un país
independiente taxista fast and the part
haber es verme y casa tipificaron en
initiative el grave fin vivir de un de
danaher ver es muy triste a saber un
separar en kant abril existe un 'reality
shows' mind erzik un hat-trick inside
punto
y ahora os estaréis preguntando si
solamente basta con 1500 firmas para
convocar un referéndum y cambiar la
constitución de todo el país cómo es
posible que mantengan tanta estabilidad
porque no se celebran referéndum de
autodeterminación todos los días una
forma de responder a esta pregunta sería
porque el ict stein es junto a catar el
país más rico del planeta tierra quien
querría separarse de sus vecinos cuando
tiene un salario medio que supera los
cinco mil dólares al mes pero como os
podéis imaginar esta no es la única
razón
[Música]
el fin de competir
guzmán de 22 henning prince element el
martes nieto de problemas
en minutos
el presidente ministra
el texto lo anterior y la es de 13
problema
en verdad
y en realidad es una iniciativa local y
vinos de libertad
en soft de los propios sponsor ya lo
habéis adivinado el leaf stein es el
país que más lejos ha llevado el
principio de la descentralización por
ejemplo en un país como suiza los
cantones es decir las regiones que
componen el país son entidades que toman
casi todas las decisiones políticas pero
en liechtenstein han un paso más
la institución política más importante
de este país es el ayuntamiento somos
iguales se gobierna en efecto en el
estrés
para que os hagáis una idea incluso la
política de inmigración está
descentralizada por ejemplo vamos a
imaginar qué queréis conseguir la
ciudadanía liberiana y vivís en riquel
[Música]
pues bien en este caso los vecinos del
pueblo convocaría en un referéndum en el
que decidirían si os aceptan o no y por
supuesto esto también afecta a los
impuestos en liechtenstein el impuesto
sobre la renta tiene dos tramos uno
nacional que es igual en todo el país y
otro es el más importante que depende
del municipio para que os hagáis una
idea vamos a suponer que tenemos un
sueldo de 100 mil francos al año que
serían el equivalente a unos ochenta y
cinco mil euros sí ya sé que es un
sueldo muy alto pero creedme el
liechtenstein es bastante común pues
bien de estos 85 mil euros tendríamos
que pagar un 5% al gobierno central y
después pagaríamos el impuesto local
por ejemplo si vivimos en riquel
pagaríamos un 8,75 por ciento es decir
que el total de nuestro impuesto de la
renta sería del 13 75% pero si en lugar
de vivir en riquel vivimos en la capital
es decir en vaduz entonces pagaríamos
algo menos en este caso sería un 12 5%
os puede parecer muy poco pero hablamos
de casi una décima parte de diferencia y
por qué ocurre esto pues porque en el
ayuntamiento de vaduz han decidido que
quieren cobrar menos impuestos y la
constitución de liechtenstein les da un
enorme margen para que fijen los
impuestos a su antojo
[Música]
y como os podéis imaginar esta
descentralización a todos los niveles
les da un montón de autonomía a los
municipios en otras palabras que tienen
suficiente libertad como para que no
necesiten separarse del país
the nation straight to get al convento
de dominicos dorado sept determinismo es
el saldo de una de nation votantes no
está bien potente corriente de los datos
transforma site
la nota de folk independence cuadrada de
centro
[Música]
datos state estocada bots
mismo de modo democrático todo modelo
clínico del pib de bolt con duda pero ya
sé lo que estáis pensando ahora que sí
que vale que todo esto funciona muy bien
el lic de stein porque es un micro
estado con menos de 40 mil habitantes
así es fácil que las cosas funcionen
pero realmente podríamos aplicar este
sistema a países más grandes entonces
wolf el singlista 9 williams ride to
live
efe
info
pero sin duda alguna la pregunta la
auténtica pregunta que os estáis
haciendo todos en este momento es
realmente podría aplicarse este sistema
político en la situación específica de
cataluña y el resto de españa ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
cataluña y snow de liechtenstein para
los que nos veáis desde latinoamérica os
tengo que explicar que españa está
dividida en 17 comunidades autónomas con
sus distintos parlamentos y sus
distintos gobiernos cataluña al menos
por ahora es una comunidad autónoma más
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y tienen sus propias leyes distintas a
las de otras regiones por ejemplo en
cataluña las corridas de toros están
prohibidas mientras que en otras
comunidades no sólo son legales sino que
incluso están apoyadas por la
administración todo esto lleva a que
muchos piensen que españa es un país muy
descentralizado tal vez no tanto como
lift stain pero similar a alemania o
eeuu pero de verdad está tan
descentralizado
[Música]
vamos a lo que realmente importa el
dinero y volvemos al ejemplo del
impuesto de la renta en españa al igual
que en liechtenstein el impuesto de la
renta se divide en dos tramos uno
nacional y otro autonómico fijaos bien
en la gráfica vamos a suponer que
ganamos veinte mil euros al año y
vivimos en la comunidad de madrid' en
este caso pagaríamos alrededor del 21
por ciento de impuesto sobre la renta
diez puntos y medio corresponderían al
tramo nacional y los otros diez puntos y
medio restantes serían el tramo
autonómico pero sin embargo si vivimos
en cataluña pagaríamos algo más en este
caso hablaríamos de 22 puntos y medio de
impuesto sobre la renta porque pues
porque en este caso el tramo autonómico
es un poquito más alto y lo mismo ocurre
en otras comunidades autónomas como
extremadura donde pagaríamos alrededor
del 21 con 70 por ciento
[Música]
ahora me diréis hombre pues esto es un
sistema muy parecido al de liechtenstein
verdad bueno no tan rápido aunque hay un
tramo autonómico de impuestos los
gobiernos autonómicos apenas tienen
margen para cambiarlo es decir que el
estado fija unos tipos y las comunidades
autónomas tienen un margen muy reducido
para subir o bajar su tramo pero no sólo
eso quien realmente recauda ese dinero
es el estado central que luego se lo
devuelve a las distintas comunidades
autónomas y es más más de la mitad del
dinero con el que se financian las
distintas comunidades autónomas no viene
de estos impuestos sino que viene
directamente del estado son las llamadas
transferencias autonómicas que
explicábamos mejor en este otro vídeo
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea en otros
países como alemania suiza o el propio
liechtenstein las regiones gastan lo que
recaudan si tienen muchos impuestos o la
economía les va muy bien pues recaudarán
más dinero que otras comunidades en
españa sin embargo más de la mitad del
dinero viene de este reparto que hace el
gobierno central esto tiene una ventaja
si una comunidad quiebra el estado la
rescata pero también tiene una
desventaja apenas tienen libertad de
actuación para poder subir o bajar los
impuestos y es más en contra de lo que
podríais pensar la tendencia es cada vez
más centralista
la armonización fiscal reabre las
heridas del estado de las autonomías
en otras palabras españa es mucho más
centralista de lo que creemos y ahora os
preguntaréis y todo esto que tiene que
ver con la independencia de cataluña
pues mucho porque antes de que estallara
todo este fervor independentista lo que
pedía el gobierno de cataluña era que le
dieran más margen de actuación en los
impuestos es más esta fue la chispa que
lo encendió todo concretamente el día en
el que el por entonces presidente de
cataluña artur más se reunió con rajoy
que no me creéis pues mirad de esta
noticia del año 2012
más a rajoy o aceptas el pacto fiscal o
te atienes a las consecuencias
exactamente así es como empezó todo pero
ahora ya nos hemos olvidado de hablar de
impuestos así que la pregunta sigue
siendo tiene el derecho de los catalanes
a votar en un referéndum si se quieren
marchar de españa o no y esto es lo que
nos respondió el príncipe hans adam
segundo y food safety commission y en
cataluña self en el auto
dentro del otros problemas fue cataluña
menor que probable
[Música]
entonces state
tutorial y tu jefe system con más de
fútbol sanción
datos de otros autores
pensadlo bien en principio parece justo
que si la mayoría de los catalanes
quieren tener su propio país nadie se lo
impida verdad pero imagina de este
escenario imaginad que hacemos el
referéndum y que el 60 por ciento de los
catalanes vota por la independencia sin
embargo la mayoría de los barceloneses
al menos según las encuestas no quiere
formar parte de ese nuevo estado catalán
es más a día de hoy ya hay algunos que
quieren incluso crear su propia
comunidad autónoma que se llamaría está
barney que haríamos en este caso qué
legitimidad tendría el nuevo gobierno
catalán para obligar a los barceloneses
oa los tabareses a estar en un país en
el que no quieren estar y cómo podemos
resolver este problema
[Música]
si aplicáramos la fórmula de leaf stain
convocaríamos varios referéndums a la
vez uno por cada provincia o por cada
municipio pero esto nos llevaría a otro
problema no es lo mismo la ciudad de
barcelona que tiene más de un millón de
habitantes que granjeña de las garrigàs
que sólo tiene 163 es decir que el
método liechtenstein tampoco sería una
solución perfecta y aquí es cuando
podemos hacer todo tipo de propuestas
podríamos dividir todo cataluña en
distintos distritos electorales
podríamos crear distintas subregiones
podríamos hacer mil cosas y nunca
encontraríamos una solución perfecta
porque esto es política os dais cuenta
de lo complicado que es todo esto no
tiene ningún sentido reducirlo todo así
estás a favor o estás en contra de la
independencia de cataluña o si estás a
favor o estás en contra del referéndum
cataluña
hispanic people
además de hacer siguiente ha vuelto
libre
- p
no es todo mucho más complicado que todo
esto y por eso os dejo con esta pregunta
creéis que se podría importar el modelo
de autodeterminación de liechtenstein a
otros países y en caso afirmativo como
podríamos hacerlo
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios
pero esperad un momento porque como os
podéis imaginar no nos hemos ido a leaf
stain sólo para hacerle un par de
preguntas al príncipe
tenemos un documental entero donde os
explicamos todos los detalles del
sistema político de este país que es
único en el mundo y lo vamos a publicar
muy pronto así que estad atentos a
nuestras actualizaciones y si esta es la
primera vez que descubres este canal
visual político recordad que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros y no os perderéis ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]